Ahmad Tejan Kabbah: Mr. Chairperson,
distinguished, faculty and students, of the
Columbia University, distinguished ladies
and gentlemen. I thank this school of international
and public affairs for the invitation at this
forum and for your kind words of introduction.
I understand that last year, Columbia University
celebrated its 250th anniversary. Let me extend,
albeit belatedly, sincere congratulations
to the entire university community. It is
fascinating that a 250 year old, at 250 years
old, Columbia is still going strong and maintaining
its exemplary standard of academic excellence.\
There are few countries whose leaders in public
life, business, science, and
humanities have not had some association
with Columbia University. Indeed,
there is hardly any country that has not
benefited from Columbia's outstanding
contribution to knowledge. Over they years,
many (inaudible) have been
fortunate enough to be a part of this
fine institution, both as students and staff.
Incidentally, my son obtained his degree
in this university. It is an honor to be
here at Columbia University and to speak
at the World Leaders Forum this
morning.
I thank you for this singular honor. This
form serves as a center for open dialogue
with world leaders, but I believe it also
provides a friendly environment for
learning for learning. In other words,
it provides some opportunity for the
audience some lessons learned in such
areas as war and peace, economic and
social development, and international
cooperation. We in Sierra Leone have
learned many challenges,
lessons over the past 14 years. I would like
to share
with you a few, mainly, conflict management,
and post conflict development.\
It is our experience in resolving conflicts
and literally building a bridge between
post conflict recovery and sustainable
development. While taking you through
conflict, we'll reflect finally on development
in this weapon free comfort zone of
Columbia University. I look forward to
learning through exchange of views on
these matters. You may be aware that Sierra
Leone has endured a decade long
internal conflict in the 1990's that unleashed
a campaign of unimaginable
bloodshed and devastation. I will not
recount here in full detail the extraordinary
brutality and immense suffering visited
upon the people of my country during the
course of the conflict, which left hundreds
of thousands dead and many more
grotesquely maimed.
The conflict also devastated our infrastructure.
As a result, this senseless
violence and wanton destruction, the conflict
in Sierra Leone became
internationally known for its horrific
atrocities, particularly the widespread
amputation of civilians and sexual violence
perpetrated against innocent women
and children. Prior to the outbreak of
the armed conflict, Sierra Leone was not
only a developing country, but also one
of the least developed in the world. It still
is. Here, the 11-year rebel conflict only
exacerbated an already fragile economy.
However, the killing and maiming were abated
and the guns were silenced by our
commit to end the conflict and the will
of the people for a return to democratic
governance. Today, one of our greatest
achievements is our adherence to the
tenants of democracy and the rule of law.
Upon assuming the presidency in
March 1996, my own personal experience
in post conflict recovery, as a UNDP
representative and resident coordinator
of the United Nation system is East and
South Africa was put to the test in my
own country. I inherited a severely battered
nation.
I was conscious of my political, constitutional,
and also moral obligation and
strive hard and give every effort to bring
an early end to the war. The population
had already become war weary and in spirit
of my knowledge of the state of our
military and its inability to prosecute
the war against the rebels, I made the
enduring, the ending of the war, my campaign
pledge. I made this pledge in the
belief, by negotiations or sound reasoning,
I would be able to talk the rebels out
of their hostile activities against a
population and persuade them to enter into
negotiations with a few concluding peace
agreements with them.
In fact, the only option I saw available to
me then was to embark on negotiations
with the rebels. Accordingly, that is
the approach that I pursued immediately after
my inauguration, despite the existent
problems concerning the capability of the
military and the fact that I was elected
president against a background of
increasing confidence of the eventual
ascendancy to power of the rebel group,
known as the Revolutionary United Front,
RUF. A cross section of my people,
including the print media, was against
negotiations with the rebels. But I knew
that the then army, not the people, had
lost the war.
And since the people were not competent in
the strict sense of the word, I
convinced them into talking with the rebels.
It was an uphill task. The areas
manifests hostility toward my government
had been further increased. Insistence
on elections before peace. This caused
the area a considerable sense of
frustration. Both of these factors, though
not fatal, will prove the weakening, the
baddening position of my government when
it entered the *Abidjan peace talks
with the (inaudible) in late 1996. In
Abidjan, a comprehensive peace agreement
was included despite all the acrimony
engendered by the rebels during
negotiations.
The agreement called for, among other things,
the total and immediate cessation
of hostilities, the disarmament demobilization,
and reintegration of all combatants
and the provision of amnesty for the (inaudible)
members. The people
(inaudible) welcomed the signing of this
agreement, as they regarded the accord
as the end of their woes and suffering
and expected that it will restore lasting
peace and stability to the country. It
soon turned out, however, that the people
and the government had in fact been deceived
by the (inaudible). The message
of the rebel leader, intercepted by the
government, only days after the signing of
the agreement, clearly showed that the
*Ariyaf did not enter the peace
negotiations in good faith and had no
desire to abide by the term's resulting
peace agreement.
And that message, for the (inaudible), the
rebel leader had communicated with
his deputy, the field commander *Sam Bokari,
alias Mosquito that he had agreed
to participate in negotiation and to sign
the peace agreement only as a pretext to
relieve himself of the pressure of the
international community. But he never
intended to abide by its terms. In the
same message, he ordered his
commanders to resolve hostilities, even
with greater ferocity. Indeed, the cease
fire, which then prevailed, was then broken
by the Ariyaf immediately after the
signing on the agreement. A clear indication
that the Abidjan agreement was
doomed on fail. Attacks on civilians by
the Ariyafs stepped up over time.
In March 1997, military officers adopted the
name Armed Forces Revolutionary
Council, in collaboration with Ariyaf
rebels, and stages a bloody coup in Fretown,
the capital of Sierra Leone. My government
went into exile in neighboring
Guinea, from where we operated and mobilized
international support for the
immediate and unconditional restoration
of democratic rule. The people of Sierra
Leone overwhelming rejoiced and rejected
the coup, some with their lives. In
response to the Ariyaf in transience and
its increasing brutality against civilians,
Nigeria led a (inaudible) observer group.
Troops launched an offensive in February 1998
to dislodge the *Jaunter. The
joint (inaudible) were forced out of Fretown
and my government was there after
restored. During the intervention, my
(inaudible), many of the Farseian area
\f0 forces escaped to the remote hinterlands
of the country and intensified their
activities predominantly in the diamond
mining areas. There, they were able to
mine diamonds which they exchanged cheaply
with weapons, which they armed
themselves to the teeth. This enabled
them to recoup, to regroup, and attack the
capital in January 1999. Slaughtering
thousands of civilians and virtually razing
the city in a matter of days.
This level of mayhem and destruction further
awakens (inaudible) general
international awareness of the plight
of the civilian population. That incursion
accelerated the dire need for the peace
process. In collaboration with the
economic committee of West African states,
a course, an international committee
was now willing to intervene, at least
diplomatically. And they, together, with the
government, were not determined to find
a workable and lasting solution to the
rebel (inaudible) in the country. This
led to the commencement of the dialogue,
which resulted in the Lomi peace agreement
of 1999.
The initial stage of the dialogue was set
when I was invited to Lo Mien Togo to
sign a cease-fire agreement for the rebel
leader for the Sanko in March 1999. I
did this, I missed a lot of misgivings
from the people of Sierra Leone. From the
bitter experience they had had regarding
(inaudible) attitude to the Abidjan peace
accord, they, on the one hand, preferred
an all out war against the rebels, and an
attainment of peace by their defeat in
battle. I, on the other hand, was aware of
the handicaps and limitations of the government
to proceed that way.
I was also aware of the pending restoration
of a democratically elected
government in Nigeria, as a result of
which the continued stay of the Nigerian
contingent in Sierra Leone, which was
by far the largest, could not be
guaranteed. Above all else, I could no
longer stomach the killing of innocent
Sierra Leonins. Thus, I chose the path
of dialogue again. But this time, careful
to
avoid the pitfalls and weaknesses in the
Abidjan peace accord. Along the lines
of the Abidjan peace agreement, the Lomi
peace accord included a blanket
amnesty for competence and provided for
disarmament and demobilization and
the reintegration of human rights and
truth and reconciliation commissions.
The parties also agreed to the deployment
of a neutral United Nations
peacekeeping force. Most notably, it also
included a power sharing arrangement
among the elected government, the Ariyaf
and rebels and the AFRC. The Ariyaf
leader for the Sanko was accorded a status
that was similar to that of the vice
president and chairmanship of the important
commission for the management of
strategic mineral resources and natural,
national reconstruction and
development. The MPC, the AFRC leader,
*Jonipul Koriman, was appointed
chairman of the disarmament and reintegration
committee. With these
arrangements, expectations were high that
Sierra Leone had turned a corner and
was on its way to lasting peace and stability.\
On January 18, 2002, Sierra Leonins breathed
a sigh of joyous relief. For that
memorable day marks the formal end of
the brutal conflict. We set ourselves
specific goals in pursuit of sustainable
peace and national development. We
shared the view that a peaceful and sustainable
environment, is a (inaudible) for
national development and by extension,
for achieving the millennium
development goals. The starting point
was disarmament and reintegration of
competence by May 2004, a total of 72,490
competents were disarmed and
71,043 demobilized, including 6,845 child
soldiers.
By the same period, 55,122 ex competents had
received support for their
integration into active committee life.
Also, most of the formerly, internally
displaced persons and refugees where repatriated
and resettled. Indeed, the war
that's killed our people and ravaged our
country had become a thing of the past.
However, in order to ensure that the long
peace is consolidated, government
(inaudible) sustainable reforms in the
security sector. The underlying strategy is
to transform the security sector so that
it is not only capable or responding
adequately to threats, to the states,
and citizenry, but also to provide the enabling
environment to fight poverty and pursues
the goals of national development.
This is particularly significant as what was
once a 17,000 person strong U.N.
peacekeeping force. (inaudible) is scheduled
to depart Sierra Leone within three
months that is by the end of this year.
As I pursued the peace process, I was
also cognizant of the fact that Sierra
Leonins were anxious. Not only to have
peace, but also to realize sooner than
the later, concrete dividends from this,
from the restoration of a democracy, of
a democratic government, which they had
obtained after much toil and suffering.
We were constantly reminding ourselves that
lack of development breeds conflict
and insecurity. How then, do you keep
the peace and maintain security under
those circumstances? While regarding peace
and security as being paramount,
we never abandoned our relief and development
responsibilities. To this end,
one of the most successful of our post
conflict initiatives was the establishment
of
a national commitment for reconstruction,
resettlement, and rehabilitation. The
three R's. While it was evidently a response
to the humanitarian development
goals, in particular, for the rural areas,
which bore the brunt of rebel aggression,
the NCRRR was in effect a bridge between
the demand for immediate
humanitarian relief and the equally important
need to prepare for a resumption of
economic development activities that had
been ruthlessly disrupted by rebel war.
After all, people cannot remain or depend
on humanitarian relief indefinitely.
Moving from relief to development, the
triple R commission was transformed into
the National Commission for Social Action.
NACSA. NACSA could be described
as the motive force for our post conflict
development. It is a showpiece in post
conflict transition. While assuming responsibility
for the previous reconstruction,
resettlement, and rehabilitation programs,
NACSA also coordinated funding for
projects that promote economic growth
and sustainable development.
Working directly with local communities, it
supports projects and programs in
such areas as water and sanitation, shelter,
public works, including agriculture,
fisheries, education, and micro financing.
With almost 1,100 projects
implemented, the ultimate objective of
NASCA is linked to our poverty reduction
strategy. As stated above, even before
the war, poverty in Sierra Leone had
become endemic and pervasive. By 1990,
statistics indicated that those, close to
four-fifths of the population lived below
the poverty line of $1 a day.
In addition to income poverty, a large portion
of the population lacked access to
basic social services, including health
care, education, potable water, and
sanitation. The war merely exacerbated
the death and severity of poverty,
causing the living conditions of the majority
to further deteriorate. Following the
election in 1996, my government began
efforts to combat widespread poverty.
We begun by identifying five broad development
priorities. One, security and
world related issues such as disarmament,
immobilization, reintegration, and
resettlement, rehabilitation and reconstruction.
Two, education. Three, good
governance and justice. Four, agriculture
and food security. And five, health, with
an emphasis on primary health care.
And in order to address these broad developmental
priorities, we devised a
poverty reduction strategy in the form
of an interim poverty reduction strategy
paper, which was completed in 2001. This
strategy was designed to support the
transition from peace keeping to peace
building and from relief to an equitable
and sustainable development. It calls
for a two-phased implementation strategy.
A transition period, 2001-02 and a medium
term phase, 2003-2005. While the
transition period focused on immediate
postwar reconstruction, resettlement and
security challenges, the medium term phase
addressed long-term development
strategy for property reduction within
the context of the preparation of a full
poverty reduction paper, PRSP.
In addition, my government also provided for
the implementation of a national
recovery strategy and (inaudible), which
was prepared and launched in October
2002. A full cost on, the consolidation
of state authority and peace building, the
promotion of reconciliation and the encroachment
of human rights. Facilitating,
resettlement and reintegration and rebuilding
communities facilitating access to
previously inaccessible areas and stimulating
economic recovery. The NRS
freeze represented the combined efforts
of government and development
partners and essentially served as a bridge
between emergency humanitarian
assistance and longer term development
challenges.
Both the IPRSP and the NRS were successfully
implemented during 2001-2004
with my government allocating significant
budget resources to form critical
poverty reduction activities, particularly
in the social sectors of health, education,
water, and sanitation. This resulted in
sustained recovery of the economy during
the period 2001-2004. Real GDP grew by
5.4 percent in 2001, 6.3 in 2002, 6.5 in
2003, and 6.4 in 2004. To consolidate
these gains, government adopted bold
economic and structural reforms geared
towards sustaining the recovery and
improving overall financial management
and service delivery.
Other reform measures have included A: improving
the strengthing, policy
making, budget planning, and execution.
B: improving the capacity for accounting
and reporting. C: reforming the public
procurement process. D: enhancing
revenue collection and mechanisms through
the creation of a national revenue
authority and E: public sector reform
generally. In order to achieve greater
efficiency in the management of public
finances, and to ensure that public
enterprises better serve the public of
Sierra Leone, we established a public
enterprise privatization commission to
oversee and monitor the oppression of
state enterprises and recommend their
privatization where appropriate.\
Beyond that, we have been preoccupied with
institutional development as a
means of not only expanding the institutional
space, but also of modernizing our
institutions so that they can provide
efficient service. Currently, Sierra Leone
is
aggressively pursuing a new strategic
direction to build towards the MDG targets.
It has formulated a 2005-2007 PRSB, which
provides bold secturial policies and
institutional reforms to achieve economic
growth, provide food security, job
opportunities, basic social service, and
efficient social security nets.
It proposes actions to address A: short term
living conditions and B: long term
causes of conflict and poverty. The poverty
reduction strategy paper constitutes
Sierra Leone's first step towards achieving
the Millennium development goals by
2015. It is (inaudible) toward long-term
poverty reduction. It is multidimensional
and achievable. As we all know, however,
neither the ongoing efforts of my
government to achieve a meaningful improvement
in the welfare of our people,
\f1 \uc0\u8232
\f0 nor our implementation of prudent fiscal
and monetary problems can ever be
\f1 \uc0\u8232
\f0 achieved if these efforts are not firmly
rooted in a solid framework of democratic
practices and good governance.
That is why we are vigorously pursuing the
goals of good governance through
several reform measures in improving the
performance and integrity of state
institutions, fiscal public sector management,
and equality of public and political
leadership. On my assumption of office,
my government immediately set up
improving the quality of governance and
later set up a governance steering
committee under the chairmanship of a
member of my cabinet. The committee
has concentrated its efforts on rebuilding
democratic governance through
constitutional and institutional reforms.
Decentralization and local government
reforms, public sector, and civil service
reforms, promotion of human rights,
judicial and legal reforms, promotion
of accountability and transparency.
The reduction of the incidents of corruption
and abuse of power. In particular, my
government views corruption as an impediment
to the promotion of good
governance. Accordingly, combating endemic
corruption is the cornerstone of our
good governance program. We have, for
the first time in the history of Sierra
Leone, appointed an ombudsman, whose role
is to investigate complaints of
abuse and capricious action on the part
of public officials. Also, for the first time
in our history, and way ahead of other
sub-Saharan African countries, we have
promulgated an anti-corruption act to
combat corruption and establish an anti-
corruption commission with the mandate
to investigate instances of alleged or
suspected corruption and to take appropriate
action, including recommendations
for prosecution.
In a bid to stimulate economic development,
the rural areas and to extend
democratic participation to the grassroots
of the population, the government
introduced legislation in early 2004 aimed
at promoting the centralization of
government services and a reestablishment
of elected local government
councils. This initiative led to the enactment
of the Local Government Act in
March 2004. Thereafter, local government
elections were held nationwide in May
\f0 of that year, in which municipal, town
and district councils were elected to replace
the (inaudible) political appointed management
committees that had been in
These elections took government closer to
the local community and considerably
empowered them to take control of the
management of their own affairs. Another
serious source of concern for my government
is that of dealing with the
dispensation of justice in Sierra Leone.
Accordingly, under the guidance of the
chief justice, the entire judicial and
legal system is in the process of being
completely overhauled. This activity,
which is aimed at developing an effecting
and efficiently held and judicial system
in Sierra Leone is part of the British
funded Law Development Reform Project.
In line with our commitment, we now
have a fully functioning law reform commission,
whose mandate is to review all
the laws of our country and to make recommendations
regarding the need for the
(inaudible) amendment or repeal of laws.
Further measures have been taken to provide
incentive and improve pay and
other conditions of service for personnel
in the legal service. The cumulative
effect of all these, public sector reform
initiatives, is that Sierra Leone is gradually
becoming the peaceful and wholesome society
that it had been known to be at
one time in the past. We are trying to
position Sierra Leone among the ranks of
leading countries in Africa. Leaders in
addressing corruption. We will be leaders
in human rights. We will be leaders in
electoral reform, we will be leaders in
(inaudible) security. We must establish
this reputation for leadership in order to
begin to attract long term foreign investors.
We need foreign investment first in the development
of infrastructure. Without
adequate energy, telecommunications, transport,
and shipping services, we will
not attract business investment. We are
doing our best to provide a regulatory
framework with particular, with predictable,
consistent, and simple procedures for
doing business. Foreign enclaves mark
our economic history, especially in the
mining and commercial sectors. The business
of these sectors must be
thoroughly integrated into our national
economy. This is usually accomplished
through the financial sector, including
the banks.
We must enable national and foreign investors
to lend and borrow money in the
local market. The financial links need
to be developed between those who have
money and those who want to invest money
in new businesses. Our banking
system is starting to vigorously respond
in the services to every district. Now, it
must expand the kind of services it provides
and become a true hub for financial
transactions between leaders, lenders,
and borrowers. The micro finance sector
is emerging, is emerging, financial services
needs to expand to include medium
sized loans, under commercial banks, and
must finance agricultural and post
harvest businesses to link agriculture
to industry.
Private sector growth does not just refer
to foreign investment. We're witnessing
a most encouraging response by farmers
on the various initiatives of fields and
schools and agricultural business units.
Last year, the minister of agriculture,
forestry and food security provided seed
rice to enable farmers to restore losses
during the war and rebuild the acreage
necessary for food security. This year, the
ministry is purchasing an additional 114,000
bushels of rice, making these two
years the largest efforts ever for government
support to expand, to the expansion
of rice production.
The agricultural business unit have pledged
to save 20 percent of their output
and make a community contribution of 20
percent to their local council. The
successful harvest in 2005-2006 and the
commitment of these farmers to their
pledges will launch a new era of agricultural
business by small farmers. This is
an encouraging development in the private
sector. We're hopeful that in 2006,
this effort will culminate in Sierra Leone
becoming once again a rice exporter.
The task of achieving our own national
development goals on the MDGs, is
daunting, especially for one of the least
developed countries of the world, a
country emerging from 11 years of armed
conflict.
While acknowledging the need to strengthen
our capacity for good governance,
mobilizing domestic financial institutions,
etc. we have to make considerable
efforts to create more jobs, to integrate
our youth into the economic and social
mainstream of society. Here, I'm referring
to the vast majority who never lifted an
AK-47 rifle against anyone. We have learned
from experience that
unemployment and disadvantaged youths
provided a pool or recruits for the
rebels. We have therefore created a new
ministry of youth and sports to enhance
our ability, through well-designed projects.
From meeting the needs of this
important segment of the population.
In this regard, we have revised our national
youth policy. It emphasizes youth
empowerment and the mainstreaming of youth
activities and concerns as critical
inputs in the development process. The
major objective is the strengthening of
partnership between the public and private
sectors to facilitate employment of
youth. In coming up with this new policy,
we realized that hard won peace as
well as our efforts for sustainable development,
would be seriously jeopardized if
we failed to address the youth problem
speedily and effectively. We have to
eliminate the rest of us sliding back
into conflict. The key lies in prevention.
We agree with the Secretary General of the
United Nations that every step taken
towards reducing poverty and achieving
broad based economic growth is a step
towards conflict prevention. We must create
a culture of prevention; one based
on renewed commitment to address in a
coordinated and comprehensive manner
the problems of economic and social development.
I have no doubt whatsoever
that this is the best means of insuring
that Sierra Leone does not slide back into
violent conflict. Ladies and gentlemen,
let me summarize what I believe, based
on the Sierra Leone experience and lessons
learned, are the key elements for
meeting the challenges of post conflict
development.
Least development countries emerging from
armed conflict face special problems
that require special attention as well
as specialized country specific solutions.
Two, sustained economic and social development
is a key to the prevention of
armed conflict. And perhaps the best means
of preventing the reoccurrence of
violence, violent armed conflict in developing
countries like Sierra Leone. Three,
useless war related emergency relief and
peacekeeping programs buttressed by
comprehensive development programs, the
prospects for lasting peace will be
dimmed.
Four, development as an instrument of conflict
prevention and durable peace
must also be considered in the context
of regional peace and security. For
instance, a strong and viable (inaudible)
union comprising New Guinea, Liberia,
and Sierra Leone would help significantly
and could alleviate most of the
problems associated with the conflicts
in the sub-region. An equally strong and
viable economy community of West African
states. Focusing on its cooperation
and integration would greatly enhance
the capacity of its member states to
prevent armed conflict. Five, the concept
of reintegration after armed conflict
should be redefined.
It should be extended beyond the placement
of ex competents in occupational
and related activities to include the
integration of youth in the mainstream of
society. And finally, small developing
countries have very limited means to
defend themselves against serious threats
to their security. Unless major powers
and collective security arraignments are
willing to provide the necessary
assistance, when these states face serious
internal disturbances and/or external
aggression, they will be doomed to perpetual
turmoil. In the next two years, now
that we have secured the peace, we will
constantly date the peace for future
generations by developing Sierra Leone.
We will be more strategic, we will be more
thorough. We will be more intolerant
of corruption. We will protect the rights
of women and children. We will secure
and improve the education of our boy/girl
and our boy and girl children. We will
continue to offer our youth the chance
for literacy to recover the basic education
they missed during the war. We will accelerate
the transformation of subsistence
farming into surplus farming. We will
build ability of our farmers to save and
invest in their agricultural businesses.
Above all, we will adhere to the tenants
of participatory democratic governance
and the rule of law. We have come a long
way, thanks to the invaluable
contribution of every Sierra Leonin in
various ways and to the support of the
international community. Of course, we
acknowledge the fact that there is still a
long way ahead of us. With commitments
and hard work on the part of every
Sierra Leonin and the support of friendly
countries and institutions, we will
achieve the millennium development goals
and targets. Finally, I hope you can
appreciate that the path to peace and
development can be rugged. However,
with determination, patience, and people's
will, proper focus, and the grace of the
Almighty, one is bound to succeed. I thank
you for your attention.
}